[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur france 3
franche comté dispositif exceptionnel
aujourd'hui dans trois semaines nous
allons choisir nos députés et d'ici
trois semaines france 3 franche comté en
partenariat avec l'est républicain et
france 2 va vous proposer 12 débat dans
les douze circonscriptions de
franche-comté 4e débat par dimanche donc
aujourd'hui le programme on va commencer
ce matin en direct ici à la gare d'eau à
besançon avec les deux première
circonscription du doubs les deux
circonscriptions de l'agglomération de
la capitale comtoise
et puis cet après midi à partir de 15h
sur nos sites internet respectifs
uniquement le débat dans la première
circonscription de haute saône vesoul
gré puis dans la deuxième du jura
champagnole saint-claude je vais
rejoindre tout de suite david mal de
france bleu besançon bernard bayot est
avec nous aussi de l'est républicain
bonjour david bonjour jérémy vous allez
nous présenter tout de suite nos
candidats mais d'abord de quelle
circonscription parlons nous ce matin la
première circonscription du doubs celle
de besançon ouest des bords du doubs
donc avec notamment à besançon le
quartier battant mont rapon planoise
évidemment jusqu'à saint vith
arc-et-senans en passant par l'art nos
ou 15 g la députée sortante c'est la
socialiste barbara romagnan élu en 2012
depuis la fin des années 80 c'est une
circonscription qui bascule
régulièrement robert schwint claude
girard jean louis fousseret et françoise
branget ci sont notamment succédé au
premier tour de la présidentielle il ya
quelques semaines c'était manuel macron
qui est arrivé en tête vous voyez les
résultats devant jean-luc mélenchon le
leader de la france insoumise qui
réalise là d'ailleurs son meilleur score
de toute la franche comté suivait vous
le voyez marine le pen françois fillon
benoît hamon et nicolas dupont aignan
david c'est à vous qui sont nos invités
et bien alors sur ce plateau de france 3
france bleu l est républicain
on retrouve la députée sortante barbara
romagnan elle est investie par le parti
socialiste et europe écologie les verts
et elle se représente dans cette
circonscription pour un second mandat
également avec nous sur ce plateau ce
matin
françoise branget elle est conseillère
départementale ex-député de cette même
circonscription elle est investie par
l'ue dei et les républicains elle est
également première vice présidente du
département du doubs également présent
avec nous ce matin josé gaona il est
suppléant d'habiba de la cour il
représente la france
insoumise il n'a aucun mandat et c'est
sa première candidature sur ces
législatives
face à lui et bien retrouve fanette
charvier la candidate de la république
en marche
elle n'a aucun mandat et c'est sa
première candidature sur ces élections
législatives
et puis aussi présents candidat eh bien
il y a le maire de servi de pascal
routier candidat divers droite il est
conseiller communautaire l'agglomération
de besançon il a dit mr 208
alors je vous précise que 1 à romano la
candidate du front national devait
participer à ce débat mais pour raisons
de santé elle a annulé sa venue ce matin
je vous précise également que sont
également candidats sur cette
circonscription laurent croizier du
modem emmanuel guérin de l'upm claudine
françois ville sert du mouvement
écologique indépendant nicole frias de
lutte ouvrière kevin may et du parti
animalistes et alain robert divers
barbara romagnan vous êtes la députée
sortante
vous étiez élu socialiste dans le
gouvernement valse le gouvernement héros
vous avez contester la politique de
françois hollande durant tout votre
mandat est ce que vous vous présentez
cette fois ci pour contester la
politique du gouvernement du nouveau
président emmanuel macron alors moi ce
qui motive mon engagement à mes prises
de position ses les engagements que j'ai
pris devant les citoyens donc c'est au
nom de ces engagements pris devant eux
en 2012 que j'ai arbitré mais chouette
vote pas toujours contre mais aussi
largement en soutien pour un certain
nombre de dossiers
vous serez toujours frondeuse lors de ce
mandat je serai toujours indépendante
j'accorde beaucoup de valeur à la
démocratie donc je pense que les
engagements qu'on compte devant les
citoyens on doit les respecter parce
qu'après autrement il faut pas qu il
s'étonner qu'ils ne veulent plus venir
voter si finalement leur vote ne change
rien eu égard au choix qu'on a fait
devant le on sait pas trop où il parti
socialiste
au cours de ces législatives le score de
benoît hamon est historiquement bas à la
présidentielle est ce que le ps actuel
est amené à se rapprocher des
communistes des mélenchonistes où vous
situez-vous certains de vos collègues se
présente clairement dans la majorité
présidentielle
ce qui est sûr c'est que je pense que la
gauche c'est à recomposer moi c'est
clairement là que je me suis tue vous
l'avez dit mes convictions donc n'ont
pas varié ça n'empêche pas de de prendre
en compte un certain nombre de
changements et d'être ouverts aux
propositions qui peuvent être faites
mais je pense que la priorité c'est bien
la refondation de la gauche et que la
gauche s'est malgré son absence au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle s'est exprimé par le vote
en direction de plusieurs candidats et
je crois que cette aspiration elle
existe toujours dans la société
françoise branget david l'a dit vous
êtes vice présidente du département
l'est républicain vous avez été député
de cette circonscription de 2004 à 2012
vous étiez conseillère régionale jusqu'à
il ya peu pourquoi vous représentez
n'était-il pas temps de passer la main
il a écouté un parlementaire voire
candidat à la députation a pour ambition
quand même de représenter ses citoyens
et puis sa famille politique et de
porter le projet de sa famille politique
alors passer la main pourquoi parce que
j'ai véritablement une légitimité par le
travail que j'ai accompli pendant toute
ces dernières années et j'ai été investi
par ma fille famille politique élargie
du centre et de la droite que ce que
sont bien évidemment lui dit et puis le
les républicains au terme d'un long
processus mais c'est aussi la légitimité
que je tire des élus de la
circonscription des élus maires par
exemple qui me soutiennent vous êtes là
pour prendre votre revanche de 2012
françois grond javier était battu le
rappel par barbara manon j'ai toujours
eu le sentiment d'un travail inachevé
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
véritablement le souci de l'avenir de la
circonscription du territoire plus
généralement par son développement bien
économique bien entendu par son
aménagement et puis surtout pour
l'avenir de ses citoyens et sa jeunesse
françoise branger est ce que vous serez
si vous êtes élue députée en soutien ou
en opposition du gouvernement
voir philippe et républicains comme vous
eh bien vous savez pendant les
discussions au parlement
bien souvent il y a des beaucoup de
dispositions qui sont adoptées par les
uns et les autres moi je me refuse à
voir au maquereau ou anti magron je ne
suis pas ni pro macro ni anti macron
nous avons un président qui a été élu
je le respecte aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans un processus démocratique
il faut qu'un gouvernement tire sa
légitimité de
de la majorité du parlement donc c'est
le principe de la 5ème constitution donc
je respecte monsieur mâcon il est le
président mais nous verrons quelle sera
la majorité à la sortie des législatives
pascal routiers vous avez entendu
françoise branger vous aussi vous êtes
candidat pour être le député de cette
circonscription
alors vous n'avez pas l'investiture les
républicains vous êtes divers droite
vous vous voulez soutenir le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe alors
moi je suis totalement indépendant bien
entendu et le but pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est après 15 années d'expérience en
tant que maire de saint vite avec la
connaissance des difficultés de nos
concitoyens je crois que il était
important de poursuivre cette aventure
et surtout la concrétiser pour
travailler ensemble avec la nation pour
redresser cette france et je crois que
j'ai en plus cette double expérience
d'être chef d'entreprise
en parallèle et connaître les
difficultés des entreprises pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui porter cette cette attente
de l'ensemble des français auprès de
l'ensemble des dégustateurs de france
est donc faux billets tout avoue pascal
routier françoise branget n'est pas une
candidate logique
françoise branget est une élue du passé
c'est une élue qui aujourd'hui veut
reprendre bien sur la route de la
législature et personnellement on peut
pas être et avoir été
fanette janvier vous êtes donc la
candidate de la république en marche des
manuels macron vous incarnez en quelque
sorte le renouvellement cher au nouveau
président de la république
le problème entre guillemets c'est que
personne ne vous connaît
peut-on se forger une
carrure de député en trois semaines de
campagne alors effectivement comme vous
l'avez si bien dit je fais partie des
nouveaux visages proposé par la
république en marche et je tiens à
rappeler 52% des investitures la
république en marche sont des personnes
qui n'ont jamais eu de mandat électif
ce renouvellement il a été souhaité est
appelée de ses voeux par emmanuel macron
je pense qu'il est important aujourd'hui
que la politique ne soit pas uniquement
une affaire de carrière politique et
qu'on laisse la place à des gens qui
n'ont jamais eu de mandat
c'est une nouvelle façon de faire de la
politique
alors perdre et en quoi vous serez une
députée crédible si vous êtes élu mais
la crédibilité aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
parce qu'on a déjà été député qu'on est
forcément plus crédible que quelqu'un
d'autre
un député je tiens à rappeler c'est
quelqu'un qui représente la nation et
qui représente les habitants de sa
circonscription
donc n'importe quelle personne pourrait
incarner les habitants de sa
circonscription l'essentiel c'est de
garder aussi un lien avec le terrain et
de porter la voix des habitants de la
circonscription vers paris alors votre
candidature quand même et contester
puisque on le sait le modem au niveau
national est partenaire de la majorité
présidentielle il y avait un candidat
modem sur cette circonscription laurent
croizier qui a maintenu sa candidature
en quelque sorte majorité présidentielle
mais dissidents comment vous l'expliquez
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie de lui
dire alors monsieur croizier je le
croise régulièrement et nous avons même
tracter ensemble pour la présidentielle
je pense que la commission nationale
d'investiture a étudié les candidatures
il ya eu dix neuf mille candidatures
pour 500
521 voix la personne retenue investi il
ya forcément eu des déçus je le conçois
toutefois la commission nationale
d'investiture a étudié les candidatures
et a décidé de m'investir donc
aujourd'hui je suis la candidate
d'emmanuel macro et de la république en
marche messieurs croisés a décidé de
maintenir sa candidature modem il en a
tout à fait le droit josé gaona vous est
le suppléant on l'a dit vous vous n'êtes
pas le candidat titulaire vous est le
suppléant d'habiba de la cour qui
représente la france
insoumise pourquoi porter cette voie ce
parti dans cette élection législative
sur la première circonscription
eh bien écoutez nous sommes issus de
classes populaires nous avons travaillé
en ce qui me concerne depuis l'âge de 14
ans l'entreprise
nous sommes en train de sortir de tout
tous ces partis politiques qui gèrent la
république depuis des décennies pour
essayer de redonner la parole au peuple
nous sommes des candidats de conviction
humaine écologique et sociale notre
projet n'est pas d'être député en soi
moi je veux être député habiba de la
courbe députés mais c'est en tant que
représentant du peuple en représentant
de la france merci ouais josé également
merci david bernard paillot va prendre
votre place bernard de l'est républicain
il va interroger
nos invités sur une thématique très
précise qu'il a choisi
bonjour bernard vous avez choisi
d'interroger nos candidats sur la
moralisation et le financement de la vie
publique
oui absolument alors on a beaucoup parlé
et pendant la campagne et en ce début de
de deux mandats de la moralisation de la
vie politique et de la transparence
alors ma première question s'adresse à
vous fanette charlier est ce que ça n'a
pas été compliqué quand on est une jeune
candidate comme vous de venir ici pour
en débattre et comment vous concevez
vous la transparence la moralisation de
la vie politique
et qu'est ce que vous pouvez apporter
alors en ce qui concerne la transparence
de la vie politique je crois qu'il ya
déjà eu beaucoup de propositions qui ont
été faites par emmanuel macron et ça
concerne évidemment le but c'est quand
même de restaurer la confiance entre les
français et leurs élus
donc il il ya des propositions qui ont
été faites qui vont être débattues
ça va être par exemple d'interdire toute
activité de conseil à des parlementaires
la proposition a été faite et ça je le
rappelle des les statuts dans marche
donc en avril 2016
la proposition a été faite en tout cas
c'est inscrit dans les statuts
l'interdiction d'embaucher un membre de
sa famille pour un parlementaire et donc
ça ce n'est pas une réaction aux
différentes affaires qu'on a pu entendre
sur sur la présidentielle
on sait que le premier ministre edouard
philippe lorsqu'il était député n'a pas
été un exemple flagrant de transparence
notamment quand il a rempli sa
déclaration d'intérêts ou d'autres
d'ailleurs il s'en cache pas est ce que
on va pas avoir des problèmes au
gouvernement avec des dissensions entre
certains membres du gouvernement pour ce
projet de loi sur la transparence
alors non non
pas de problème puisque tous les membres
du gouvernement se sont engagés dans le
projet d' emmanuel macron je rappelle
que d'ailleurs il ya eu un petit temps
on a été un petit peu retardé au niveau
de la nomination du gouvernement c'était
justement pour que la la commission pour
la transparence de la vie publique
puisse examiner justement attentivement
chacun des membres du gouvernement et
vérifier qu'il n'y avait qu il n'y avait
aucun problème là dessus il ya dans ma
deuxième question porte sur le
financement de vos campagnes respectives
alors pour la première circonscription
vous avez un plafond de 70000 euros
donc je voudrais savoir si vous avez
consommé l'intégralité des 70000 euros
dont la moitié remboursés par l'état
si vous avez souscrit après personnel et
c'est qui qui vous aide dans le
financement de votre campagne
donc je me tourne vers vous barbara
romagnan qui était très en pointe sur ce
sujet pour savoir comment vous allez
faire
j'ai souscrit un prêt personnel et jean
dépenserait à peu près la moitié
c'est-à-dire ce qui ce qui est remboursé
je fais comme je pense tout le monde
appelle à des soutiens et je pense que
si ces questions elles sont vraiment
importants de babar moi je dis que je
jeu autant je serai une opposante très
active sur toutes les questions les
reculs économiques et sociaux
vraisemblable qui risque d'arriver au
temps emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement pourra compter sur mon
soutien plein et entier sur la question
de la transparence d'autant que les
engagement que je prends à titre
personnel je vais déjà déjà appliquée
dans les cinq dernières années parce que
j'ai fait tout ça est consultable sur
mon blog j'ai fait la transparence sur
tous les moyens publics qui sont mis à
ma disposition je n'en tire pas une
gloire je pense que c'est vraiment le
minimum vital ces moyens sont mis à
notre disposition pas à titre personnel
mais en tant que représentant des de nos
concitoyens donc c'est bien normal
qu'ils sachent ce qu'il en est et je
pense est important aussi parce que
quand on ne dit pas comment c'est
utilisé il ya des soupçons
même s'ils ne sont pas fondées et ses
soupçons fragilise la démocratie une
même question pour vous madame brand
j'ai donc 70000 euros intégralité
financement moi je dépenserai à peu près
la moitié comme d'habitude j'ai fait un
près de 30000 euros pour financer la
campagne électorale voilà
et je ne dépasserai pas ce plafond est
ce que vous êtes favorable à plus de
transparence notamment sur la réserve
parlementaire parce que ça va vraiment
changer une large série toujours été
favorables à la transparence
j'ai moi-même cosigné une proposition de
loi pour justement l'utilisation des
frais de mandat il ya déjà déjà un
certain nombre d'années et je suis très
attentive à l'utilisation de l'argent
public
j'ai été moi même détentrice par ma
profession d'argent public j'étais
redevable devant la loi du premier
centime d'euro et je trouve anormal que
nous n'ayons pas à justifier
effectivement de nos dépenses cantier
quant à la réserve parlementaire puisque
vous me posez la question
et bien moi je reste favorable à la
réserve parlementaire
j'ai toujours été également transparente
puisque j'ai toujours annoncé pour qui
je et pour quelles communes ou
associations jean faisait profiter parce
que c'est indispensable justement sur le
territoire de pouvoir accompagner des
petits projets qui sont soutenus par les
communes je n'ai jamais fait dit de
différence entre la couleur politique
des mères à qui jacques or des jeux pré
l'arize la réserve parlementaire c 130
mille euros que chaque député dispose
annuellement pour soutenir des projets à
des collectivités locales ou à des
associations des projets précis bernard
on continue le tour de table
alors justement j'avais une question sur
la réserve parlementaire on va faire
coup double avec mathieu routhier donc
sur le financement de sa campagne
est ce que la réserve parlementaire a
encore un sens aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut pas annoncés à
l'avancé comment on va l'utiliser alors
pour ma part bien sûr j'ai souscrit un
prêt 1 pour cette campagne
et puis c'est tout à fait normal
aujourd'hui qu'on soit les plus clair
possible vis-à-vis de nos habitants et
aujourd'hui je crois que tous ses
comptes de campagne devrait être sur
internet et présentées à l'ensemble de
la population ça ne me gêne absolument
pas bien sûr j'ai dis donc c'est jusqu'à
maintenant pour la réserve parlementaire
réserve parlementaire ce qui a été mis
en oeuvre d'ailleurs me convient très
bien je crois que c'est important
après il ya certainement une réforme à
mettre en oeuvre
dans le cadre de la moralisation aussi
c'est que ces réserves parlementaires
soient vraiment équitable sur l'ensemble
du territoire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
l'on distribue un petit peu en faveur
des personnes que l'on préfère
et donc je crois que ces répartitions
aussi elles ont lieu sur un territoire
elle doit de fait elle doit être fait
d'une façon totalement partial et
intelligente
josé ghana sur cette question alors je
pense que nous sommes les seuls à la
france soumise à voir proposer la
révocation des élus
lorsque ils ne tiennent pas leur parole
quant à leur mandat et je pense que
personne ici autour de la table mais
pour cette mesure
pourquoi en plus nous demandons lige dit
néjib élites et de tout candidat à toute
élection qui seraient mises en examen ou
qui auraient fauté
voilà pourquoi les autres candidats ne
préconise pas cela pour quoi ils sont
tous contre notre projet de révocation
des élus d'angers une dernière question
concernant l'encadrement de la
rémunération des députés qui a annoncé
parmi les projets donc je rappelle que
le salaire brut c'est de l'ordre de 5000
euros indemnité indemnités il ya des
frais de représentation de l'ordre de
5000 euros
vous avez 9000 euros pour
vos assistants parlementaires ma
question est la suivante est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut encadrer justement la
rémunération ou est-ce qu'il faut
limiter le nombre de députés barbares
omon on peut faire les deux mais de
toute façon encore une fois c'est de
l'argent public donc d'une en toile
publiciser et de deux évidemment ça doit
être encadré ce qui sert pour la
rémunération des collaborateurs
parlementaires ne doit servir qu'à ça et
pour le reste on doit dire comment
est-ce que c'est utilisé on doit fixer
des règles avant parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment beaucoup trop flou
c'est pour ça que moi je la publie cette
utilisation sur mon blog chaque année
sur la fiscalisation un peu plus
importante de l'indemnité de frais de
mandat représentative de frais de mandat
qui est dans le projet d' emmanuel
macron vous y êtes favorable également
non je ne suis pas favorable à ça parce
que ça voudrait dire que c'est des
indemnités qu'on garde pour nous et moi
je suis pour que cette indemnité ne sert
bien qu'à l'exercice du mandat et qu'on
dise bien à quoi ça sert en aucun cas ça
ne peut se retrouver dans la poche du
parlementaire c'est pour ça que la
réponse n'est pas la fiscalisation à mon
sens un noël janvier vous comment vous
abordez justement ces questions
d'encadrement des rémunérations des
députés puisque c'est une proposition
qui vient des bagages au micro oui alors
effectivement je pense que il est
important que l'ensemble des revenus
de ce que touche le député soit soumis à
l'impôt dont l'irfm je pense aussi qu'il
est important mais en tout cas c'est ce
que je proposerai la réserve
parlementaire elle est utile sur le
terrain pour pouvoir financer donner un
coup de pouce à des associations
localement et à porter des projets de
cette semaine on sait à l'avancé
utilisation voilà en revanche moi le
problème c'est qu'il ya un risque de
clientélisme
donc ce que je propose c'est tout
simplement que l'utilisation de la
réserve parlementaire soit soumise à
l'avis de jurys citoyens
merci beaucoup fait naître charvier
merci bernard david va nous rejoindre
david vous a écouté religieusement
depuis quelques minutes
est ce que il ya des points david que
vous souhaitez approfondir avec
françoise branger françoise branget vous
nous avez dit il est anormal de ne pas
justifier de nos dépenses
justement avec eux vous êtes en totale
contradiction avec ce que disait le
candidat à la présidentielle françois
fillon qui disait ça ne regarde que les
députés la façon dont on dépense et dont
on ne lui ont fait usage de nos crédits
de parlementaires écoutez comme je l ai
dit tout à l'heure je viens du privé
j'étais j'avais une entreprise où je
suis et gérait des fonds publics et j'ai
été surprise de voir effectivement que
dans la vie publique et bien on n'avait
pas à justifier de ses investissements
et de la dépense de l'argent public donc
j'ai toujours été sûr sur ce registre là
vous a pas entendu françois bon là
durant la coque présidentielle d'hier
françois fillon je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous parce que ce sont des
pratiques qui existent depuis des
dizaines d'années au sein du parlement
où on ne justifie pas justement de ces
dépenses est comme gelée dit j'avais du
mal à gérer votre parti sial et déjà
proposé une proposition de loi il ya
plusieurs années pour que justement avec
d'autres parlementaires parce que nous
étions sur ce registre là effectivement
la justification comme dans le privé de
toutes nos dépenses alors une
fiscalisation des indemnités de frais de
mandat jeunes les frais de mandat
servent à exercer le mandat
donc je ne vois pas comment on peut les
fiscaliser
c'est une proposition qui à mon avis
n'est pas tout à fait raisonnable mais
ceci dit je suis bien pour cette
transparence transparence aussi tout le
monde et pour la transparence en fait
sur ce plateau
le maire de saint vite monsieur routiers
vous c'est quoi la transparence d'après
vous on a c'est quoi la différence sur
la transparence avec la candidate des
républicains françoise branger il est
fondamental c'est de transparence un
choix que nos concitoyens attendent
elle est un peu timorée bien entendu de
la part du programme de monsieur macron
je pense qu'il faut aller en profondeur
est vraiment aujourd'hui la transparence
au niveau de tous les fonds qui sont
distribués et bien entendu des
indemnités qui sont alloués doivent être
très clair vis-à-vis de nos populations
falette charvier vous avez dit je suis
pour des jurys citoyens
oui qu'est ce que c'est que ces jurys
citoyens et jury citoyen tout simplement
c'est d'appeler des personnes de tous
horizons pour déterminer ensemble avec
eux ce qui sera le plus utile pour
l'utilisation de la réserve
parlementaire
barbara romagnan vous avez dit j'ai déjà
mises en pratique la transparence vous
étiez macro nien avant l'heure ce n'est
pas une spécificité des manuels macro
mais en effet moi j'ai pas simplement
proposé je les fais encore une fois tous
les citoyens peuvent le vérifier puisque
c'est en ligne depuis le début de mon
mandat mais moi je proposerai aussi la
création d'un d'un collectif une espèce
de comité citoyen qui sera tiré au sort
à la fois pour contrôler le fait que je
respecte les engagements que j'ai pris
devant les citoyens et pour
m'accompagner dans l'élaboration
législatives et je mettrai à disposition
à leur disposition des moyens de
l'indemnité représentative de frais de
mandat justement pour qu'ils puissent
fonctionner pour pouvoir auditionner des
gens acheter des livres en bourse et des
indemnités de frais kilométriques en un
mot barbara romagnan moralisation de la
vie politique c'est aussi pas seulement
la transparence et le cumul des mandats
si vous êtes élu c'est votre dernier
mandat
en tout cas ce sera le seul comme je m'y
étais engagé quand j'ai été élu en
octobre dernier comme c'est peut-être
pas le dernier puis peut-être que ça
s'arrêtera maintenant ça c'est aux
concitoyens d'en décider mais en tout
cas je m'étais engagé l exercer de façon
exclusive c'est ce que j'ai fait que je
continuerai à faire
josé gravona vous sur la transparence
vous avez dit on est les seuls à
proposer la révocation des élus
si vous ne jouez pas les règles du jeu
vous êtes prêt à sortir de l'assemblée
nationale si les citoyens sont sont
contre ou ne sont pas satisfaits de
votre mandat bien sûr de toute façon on
n'est pas élu député par un parti ce
n'est pas vrai les gens sont mis en
place par les parties et ensuite ils
doivent répondre à ces partis nous nous
sommes à côté de cela d'accord la france
insoumise
c'est un groupement de citoyens d'accord
et nous sortirons bien sûr si nos
électeurs disent vous ne faites pas
votre travail on arrive au terme de ce
débat on va vous donner 40 45 secondes
chacun pour conclure pour vous adresser
aux électeurs de cette 1ère
circonscription et les inciter à voter
pour vous commencez avec vos fenêtres
charvier emmanuel macron est arrivée
nettement en tête du premier tour et a
été élu président de la république le 7
mai nous avons accompli et vous avez
accompli la moitié du chemin depuis le
gouvernement qui a été constituée
respecte les principes de parité de
probité
il fait appel à toutes les familles
républicaines politique est également
une large part aux compétences de la
société civile libérez protéger et
réconcilier seront les trois actions les
trois piliers de ce gouvernement
les 11 et 18 juin prochain je vous
invite à aller au bout du chemin à voter
pour les candidates et les candidats de
la république en marche et redonner sa
chance à une france conquérante fière de
ses valeurs et de sa culture
pour faire face aux défis du monde
pascal routier votre conclusion
je suis l'élu de terrain je connais les
difficultés de mes concitoyens
aujourd'hui je veux être simplement un
député utile absolument pas dans
l'opposition
je ne veux pas être un élu béni oui oui
qui ne dit que oui
ou que non en fonction des projets qui
seront proposés je m'inscris bien
entendu dans une collaboration totale de
façon à ce que les bonnes lois qui
seront votés soient mises en oeuvre pour
nos concitoyens et notre nation surtout
qui en a besoin
josé gaona votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît eh bien écoutez il faudrait que
l'on fasse une opposition très forte à
monsieur macron le projet il faut que
les francs comtois le savent le sache
le projet c'est avec le ceta par exemple
que la saucisse de morteau que le vin du
jura queue leu leu compter puisque nous
venir des etats-unis ou du canada
puisque les aop seront supprimés ça il
faut que les francs comtois le sache
je demande donc à tous de voter pour la
france insoumise pour que nous puissions
avoir un véritable contre-pouvoir à la
destruction de notre système de santé de
retraite et de travail françoise branger
et bien moi je souhaite porter un projet
vraiment alternatif pour le pays qui
puisse effectivement protégé les
français
arrêté le matraquage fiscal et donner un
avenir à notre jeunesse et je souhaite
par dessus tout aussi défendre les
intérêts de l'avenir de notre
circonscription et plus généralement du
département c'est pour ça que j'invite
tous les électeurs à se porter sur ma
candidature le 11 juin
merci françoise branger barbara romagnan
je pense que le souhait de l'élection
présidentielle était justement plutôt un
non choix donc c'est important que
pendant cette législative les gens
puissent affirmer leur choix et la
diversité politique
moi je serais une députée indépendante
comme je les ai toujours été
indépendante du pouvoir au nom du
respect des engagements de prix devant
les citoyens je serai aussi une députée
vigilante à la fois opposante sur ce que
je crains qu'ils risquent d'arriver sur
les questions économiques et sociales
parce qu'on voit que la droite est très
largement au pouvoir sur ces questions
là mais aussi un soutien actif sur les
questions écologiques et de justice sur
lesquels on peut attendre des avancées
et puis je serai aussi une députée qui
portera la solidarité qui sera une porte
parole de ce qu'on écoute pas beaucoup
de ceux qui sont souvent trop fragiles
pour pouvoir être entendue je considère
que c'est aussi mon rôle et c'est aussi
le sens du soutien de régis aubry qui
est mon suppléant et qui est le chef d
en vis de soins palliatifs de l'hôpital
et qui connaît bien et travaille bien
ces questions de la rade merci barbara
romagnan je rappelle que sur cette
circonscription sont également candidats
anna romano du front national elle était
invitée elle a annulé ce matin également
candidat laurent croizier du modem
emmanuel guérin de l'upper claudine
françois ville their du m me nicole
fraysse et l'eau kevin meyé animalistes
et alain robert partie divers merci à
tous les 5 vous allez quitter ce plateau
vous allez être remplacé laisser bien
vos micros s'il vous plaît sur les
tables par les candidats de la deuxième
circonscription du doubs le